the Joe Rogan experience HBO signs off
on a lot of outrageous ideas do you know
what they're doing yeah I mean they made
game our own so they probably like well
we we know it we got it yeah yeah yeah
where the [ __ ] well they hit a home run
for sure of every cycle of shows they
always have fun that goes oh my god did
you watch The Outsider
no it's great I watched make millions
that was fantastic I didn't see that oh
that's the McDonald's one is that each
pillow as well it's HBO yeah good my
cousin made that it's greatly your
cousin cousin made it no sure yeah it's
fantastic it is such a cool [ __ ]
story the whole scope of that scam is it
will [ __ ] blow your mind
what is the scam so it was a lottery
thing that from so you obviously
remember the Monopoly game that you
would play I don't so weak though yeah
oh you're kind of healthy but back back
[ __ ] so but it was humongous so what
happened was they would do it like maybe
like twice a year where they would go
the monopoly McDonald's game and what
happened is you go to McDonald's and you
would buy a happy meal a Big Mac and on
like the fries and the drink would be
like a peel-off thing and you could win
prizes so you pull off a thing and you
like you could win it could be it's
something as small as like you want free
fries so you could be like yeah I got
you know I won another order of fries or
a coke or a jet ski or a car and then
there were cash prizes million dollar
prizes so by by playing the game which
was essentially buy something buy a meal
and it would drive up sales obviously
right like sales would go way up because
people were wanting to win these prizes
well everybody that one for this I want
to say I forget now but like 15 year
period or something they were all in on
a scam they were all fake winners a guy
was stealing pieces and giving them to
people connected to him it was all a lie
nobody was legitimately how did he do
that
that's the whole that's the series man
it's [ __ ] fascinating because at one
point there's this the this guy's giving
it to you know people he knows and
they're talking about it in the series
like people connected to him they're
like after a while it's like it's weird
that you know 10 winners have have won
in like this 300 mile radius and eight
of them are Italian we're like we gotta
branch out a little bit because no one's
like tipped off yet because the guy was
you know Italian he was going like
friends and family yeah it was it was
really [ __ ] crazy
and then amazing they kept their mouth
shut they've kept their mouth shut and
they would have gotten away with it I
mean they were getting away with it
it was just it was they got tipped off
FBI got tipped off and then this whole
investigation that's what the series
it's a six-part series that's what it
reveals is just the scale and the scope
of this incredible scam it was a scam
and did this guy work for McDonald's no
there's all these different characters
in it but basically McDonald's had to
hire a company that would oversee the
game like the security of the game and
they would also have to hire another
company to print you know like the game
pieces and all that and within those
companies the corruption light
McDonald's didn't know and it it but the
story is fast and the characters are
outrageous to us I mean the Colombo
family is part of it you know the crime
family I gotta watch it it's good man
it's really good there's so many of
those Multi series or multi show
documentaries now that are fascinating
oh yeah like wild wild country like that
kind of [ __ ] where you just like white
and win it and when these networks get
behind something like that like this
Tiger King two things you're like man
you know that's why you need that
platform right like an HBO yeah it looks
to be like tell us the whole story right
it's [ __ ] awesome yeah
or wild country country you need
something that's gonna play out for five
or six episodes after or three episodes
in you like what how the [ __ ] did I not
know yeah
what was that one do you remember the
one a couple years ago was at the
staircase something like that about I
never saw that one that was [ __ ] good
someone killed his ex-wife first yes yes
dude and and you just cannot believe
some of the twists and turns of
something like this it's just and then
there was like that part of that I mean
I'm jumping around and the Apple theory
where they're like maybe an owl came and
attacked her and that's what yes yes yes
and they were like there are hours in
that area it could have happened like
people have all these conspiracy
theories it's amazing
[Applause]